okay good afternoon everybody this is
Peter Cooper again
this is a webinar on dealing with one of
the web blasts tabular format if you
have a question during the webinar
please type it in the question pod Rana
Morris from the Service Desk who works
with me will be here to sort of field
some of those questions we will deal
with some substantial ones at the end if
there's time if there's not time we'll
definitely answer them in a Q&A document
and all that stuff is going to be linked
to our webinars and courses page there's
also a compressed link to the materials
directory on the FTP site it's going to
have the slides it's going to have some
text documents that has some a little I
hate to call them scripts but a little
command line things that I've made for
this webinar and other things including
the Q&A document so rana can probably
send that out to you via the chat pod in
a few moments okay so let's get started
with the content so we're going to talk
about using the web blasts tabular
format by the way my email address is on
there if you have direct questions about
this material you can write to me peter
cooper at nih gov will see at the end if
you want questions about the webinar
we'll save those for a different email
address so what we're going to do is
today is learn how to download the hit
table from your blast results and we're
going to use unix/linux tools to process
the tabular output we're also going to
use a direct to get additional
information on the database matches
we'll talk more about what I mean by
that in a second and we'll combine the
new information back into a tabular
format so you can basically add columns
to the tab format to get more
information and then we'll just show you
at the end suppose you had a bunch of
sequences that are in your blast output
and you want to download them I'll show
you how to do that with the direct
program a fetch
okay so we know that many people are
interested in saving blast results and
so in the old days I know that many
cases people would literally print out
the pairwise format from the web page
and save it in a notebook this is no
longer an option
and it's really not a good idea anyway
but it's useful to save this stuff in
some format that you can archive it
there are several options here
on the one we're going to focus on today
is a real nice option because it's
compact it's called the text it's called
the head table format it does contain
abbreviated information I'll talk more
about how it's abbreviated in a moment
and of course there are structured
outputs that's for a more advanced
audience and if you want to deal with
the structured output and you have ways
of dealing with it that's great
XML is a good choice and actually there
is a webinar on a YouTube channel on how
to use the e direct program extract to
parse that output but we're going to
talk today about the hid table format
and how to deal with it so basically
what you get with the hit table text
which is what I'm going to talk about
there is a CSV comma separated variable
format we won't deal with that one
that's the same stuff it just doesn't
have any headers on it so it doesn't
have your columns labeled for you so
many people would probably prefer this
one the advantage of this format and
this is what a lot of people do with
this it's easily open and manipulated
with spreadsheet software like Excel
there may be other spreads to you
software's I'm not aware of them it's a
compact file it doesn't think of a whole
lot of room but the problem of course is
that it's abbreviated it doesn't
directly contain some useful information
for example it doesn't have sequence
titles it doesn't have two taxonomy
information and it doesn't have links
for example to get the match sequences
and we'll see how to add all that stuff
in a few minutes
so the way we're going to do that is
we're going to use simple unix linux
command line tools that are good for
working with text files and columns
there's a whole ton of these the ones
we're going to use today are a cut and
paste and sort and those are all the
names of commands you can run on the
command line and then there's Auk which
is really a programming language and
it's a world unto itself it's sort of
the ancestor of languages like Perl but
we're going to use it in a very limited
way today just right now if you are an
advanced scripter and you know a hell of
a lot about you and excuse me like a lot
about unix this probably isn't for you
you know more about this than I do but
this is for people who you know have
sort of modest needs to deal with this
and so we'll show you some simple ways
to do it
we're going to also use a direct the
program Z fancy post you linked and
extract to work with this so you may say
to yours
what if I don't have a UNIX legs machine
well it's okay if you have a Windows
machine you can use the application
cygwin which you can easily get from the
web download it install and it's
basically a Linux like environment and
you could work with all these programs
there on Mac you do have a Unix Linux
system and you can get to it from the
terminal application so this could take
a moment to mention on tray direct this
is a command line version of the
e-utilities and we have given webinars
about this and there's lots of good
information available in the
documentation there and the bookshelf
and we're going to use that and it's
installed on our machines here at NCBI
you could easily install it on your
Windows or Mac or Linux machine number
of different programs in there I won't
spend much time talking about them we'll
just learn how to use them briefly okay
and basically here are the different
programs they all interact with
something called the history server at
NCBI you post some IDs up there those
IDs could come from a search then you
retrieve those IDs in whatever format
you want
most commonly that retrieval is in the
form of an XML record and you use
extract to parse out things from that
XML we're going to do that today
there is a webinar on this as you can
see on our YouTube channel as well
so typically direct process or would be
something like this you have your
starting with IDs now you could get them
from the programming search we won't
talk about e search today but say we
have some IDs we put them into e fetch
and we piped that that's the UNIX pipe
to the other program extract and we're
going to try to get some information out
of that using this parser extract if we
have lots of IDs we might want to use e
post to put them up into the history
server retrieve them and then use
extract to parse them out likewise we
could get the links from those that we
want to have our protein records link to
PubMed we can follow those links and get
the information we want for those PubMed
records using extract after we fetched
them when you extend this whole process
of dealing with blast output
you're basically going to take the
tab-delimited output that we have and
we're going to do things with it with
all cut pace and sort and we're going to
pass that to e direct we're going to
take that data that we get back from E
direct and put it back into the tabular
output using those UNIX command-line
programs are cut paste and sort and so
on here's a complicated example that I
hope to get to today where we're
basically going to take our blast output
we're gonna get some information out of
it using awk we're gonna post those IDs
that we get using awk to be fetch we're
gonna pull them down get some
information out of them with extract
we're going to sort that information by
a particular column in the output we're
gonna take that file actually and paste
an output stream into it to get a much
larger tab delimited file and use cut to
get rid of an extra column it's in there
so that's sort of a workflow that you
could do that uses a bunch of different
tools and there are the e direct
programs here sort of at the beginning
of that with a bunch of post processing
using UNIX command-line tools so here's
what we're gonna do when you use awk
they add links from blast matches to
broken records at NCBI they're going to
do some stuff with either act we're
going to use the Posey fetch and extract
the good sequence titles taxonomy IDs
we're going to use the UNIX sort paste
and cut the process this output we're
going to take a brief look at some other
applications so we could get some
publications we could get some taxonomy
information from our blast output and
we'll use e fetch and sequence formats
to download the fast eight proteins if
time permits I don't know if it will
I'll just point out to you the
nucleotide coding region output you can
get from the fast a cDNA so let's go
ahead and get started on those and if
you want to follow along you can try or
if you want to see what I'm doing there
are a number of different files on the
ftp site that are in that link but you
don't need to do that I'm just going to
be playing along with that and you can
follow what I'm going to do is I'm going
to show you a lot of the times we're
going to be working on this command line
here this is a terminal window that goes
into one of the Linux servers at NCBI
and I'll copy
bass because typing them would take too
long some commands that we're gonna use
today to do the things that we talked
about so let me just get I'm gonna need
a little cheat sheet here that I'm going
to copy/paste from and that's this file
which is a command only text file it's
up there on the FTP site and it has the
basic commands that I'm going to type in
now so the blast certs that I'm going to
do is I'll use the human protein
creatine kinase be against Firmicutes
bacteria against the NR database this is
a search that's kind of arbitrary but
useful in a way because it shows it's
got a small set output makes it easier
to work with and actually I have that up
here in a web browser what I've done
already is I've expanded the download
options here but just to say here's my
output I've got 20 hits you're probably
all familiar with this and I want to
download this so I can simply open this
here pick the one that I want so I want
to pick the hit table text I can
download that and I can put it here I've
already saved it as this see KB
Firmicutes + p text and I can say that
I've already got it there so I won't do
that and I'm gonna be working in this
directory on one of our machines
ok so first thing let's do I'm going to
go over to the command prompt now let's
go ahead and take a look at what this
looks like so I'm just going to use a
real simple UNIX command to do that and
actually just so I don't have to type
because I'm a poor typist I'll go ahead
and just type just copy-paste this so
that's just gonna dump that to the
screen copy that paste it in and in case
it gets long I'm just going to type it
into the UNIX program more so here is
what the hit table looks like it's got a
big header at the top telling you all
the details of my search then there
tells you what the fields are those are
the column headers notice that there are
some things we have to pay attention to
the column headers are separated by
commas we were not going to deal with
that right now we're just going to
realize that we can deal with that if we
want to these columns are set
operated by a tab character and that's
the character we're going to be using to
sort of parse this a major the proteins
that we match those are the things that
are probably of most interest to us um
now if I wanted to I could open this in
Excel and I have already done that it
just opens directly you just have to
tell it about those commas so you get
your column headers here and here I've
even added a column of the links it will
show you how to do that in a moment so
this is the same file that i just opened
with excel so we know how this then we
know i've already enhanced it by adding
the link and i'll show you how to get
those links in just a moment okay so the
first thing we want to be able to do is
to get those that column that has the
accession numbers for the proteins out
of there so we're going to use auch and
i don't really have time to talk a whole
lot about off but i'll just well take a
quick look at this command line and tell
you what it does okay so this is the awk
command line we're going to use to get
the column two so this says awk this is
a command line processor here so it says
separator the fields is a tab character
and this says let's only look at things
that have more than one field in them so
that's going to be all the things that
have the rows it's going to void the
headers and things like that and this
just says print the second column and
this is the file we're going to use and
I'll just pipe that into head actually I
don't have to it's only 20 IDs so we'll
do that there they are so that's the
accession version of all the 20 proteins
that we matched in the database now you
know I know I'm going fast and you can't
copy all this stuff down this is all in
that text file that's on the FTP site
all these command lines are and that's
the one that I'm looking at right here
I'm just going to clear my screen so if
you want to retrieve a protein from
entree all you have to do is use this
base URL which says you know NCBI then
protein then the accession number so if
I do that there it is right there
here's my purging well it might be handy
to have that as a set of links in the
file so what I can do is use another use
walk again in a very sort of simple way
basically it will print that as part of
the print statement here then it will
print dollar sign too which is the
second column and then I will have
basically a set of links that I could
just copy paste into my excel file so
this is just basically a print statement
since I know the base URL is consistent
and then there you have it you could
simply n copy paste that if you want to
if you wanted to enhance this a little
bit suppose you wanted to make sure
these links retreated the fast a format
that's easy enough all you have to do is
realize that there's a simple URL for
doing that that just basically adds this
and report fast day to the end of that
so that's just a little bit of an
embellishment but it's something that
you might want to be able to do again
you could just copy paste that into your
file if you want you can use a more
sophisticated thing and basically use
awk to create a file that has this as
the last column and that command line is
right here and I won't bother to do that
one for you but basically that just says
print the first line in the file and
then add to the end of it a column that
contains this URL okay so that's how we
could do a simple thing of adding
enhancing our output with links the
other thing we want to be able to do is
to get some more information about the
sequences and so we're going to use
extract the e fetch to do that and
extract so let me just go ahead and get
one of the proteins from the file I'm
gonna pipe it in a more so you can see
if this is going to give me the document
summary XML and what I'm going to want
to pull out here is suppose I want to
get the title that would be useful to
get I could also get for example the
taxonomy ID out of here
okay there's a tax ID and if I needed to
get it I could get the accession dot
version which is down here at the bottom
and so you can read how to do that kind
of stuff in edirect but it's basically
pretty straightforward just set up a
command line to do that
and here's one right here it's going to
get me the accession version the title
and the tax ID out of that XML so I've
got the title I've got the accession dot
version and I've got this item on the
last column here is going to be the tax
ID I could use that later on if I wanted
to go into the taxonomy database to get
more information how do I do this for
all of my IDs I need to use e post so u
post has a real simple sort of syntax
you can always see the options for any
of the redirect programs by simply
typing the help at the end so that's all
the things I can do with you folks but
don't take a list of ID's and I can put
them in the history and then work on
them so the command line that will do
that for you with all of our IDs it's
just taken the exact same awk command
that we used before to get those IDs
from the file and then I'm going to
parse all this information out using
extract this is going to probably wrap
around the screen so it might be a
little ugly to see in the output we'll
go ahead and do it there they all are
okay so now I have all this information
I could you know as we saw a minute ago
I could paste this into my file but you
might notice something and that's that
these things are in a different order
than they are in the excel file so what
I have to do is to sort these by
something the thing that I can then I
could sort the excel file in exactly the
same way and then add this back in so
we're just going to use a UNIX command
sort to do that kind of thing
so I file the first column there is the
accession dot version I can sort by that
the top of the screen put it back in
so our just piped the output here so
here we're doing the workflow we're
talking about we're starting with a UNIX
command-line tool we're going into e
direct then we're finishing with a UNIX
command-line tool sorting so now these
are sorted by accession I need to do
this because what I want to do is to go
back in and sort the other tabular
output by accession so I can get the
body of that table to line up so I can
take the exact same command line that I
had before just add sort but now I'm
going to have to sort by the second
column because that's where the
identifier I'm interested in is and I
can save it if I want to so I'm just
gonna save that for us so I'm going to
use a redirection output operator there
the greater than sign to put that into a
file it didn't take long the reason is
because this was local data that I had
because notice we're just processing the
file we're not doing anything here and I
can just more that if you want now it's
sorted by accession in exactly the same
way that the output was a minute ago now
there's a rather long command line which
is the sort of file version of this
where I take these two things and paste
them together to make this output you
could also just simply take this output
right here copy it
well first you want to do is you want to
sort your Excel spreadsheet by by this
column the accession once you do that
you could paste the two files though you
could just paste this into Excel to get
your additional columns that first one
into Excel this is what you're sorted
Excel spreadsheet would look like I can
do that computationally or on the
computer by combining a bunch of
different
this will get a little ugly because it's
going to be a long table now so I've
added another UNIX command at the end of
this and that's the program paste paste
is going to take this sorted hit table
text file and now the little dash there
says standard output because the way I'm
going to do is I'm going to take this
make a stream here of the just
retrieving that information that we did
a few minutes ago to get the additional
information from you fetch it and now we
have it's kind of funny to watch because
it's wrapped around but notice this is
the file exactly what we talked about
doing the only thing that's a little bit
awkward now is that what we're going to
have to deal with is the fact that we
have two columns of the hit accession
number here that was just used to line
the two tables up you can remove that
easily with a command that uses cut cuts
a thing that works with columns if I
could just tell it cut this column right
here out and use a version a switch
called complement that says give me
everything except that column and you
would get the table back right that's
enough of that kind of stuff let's move
on to talking about getting sequences
and then we'll finish up okay the final
version of that command is right here in
this file on the FTP site couple things
to mention there is some command lines
that I could use if I wanted to get you
know links to PubMed for one of the
records and you could do the same kinds
of things with this information that we
did with the other things likewise
there's an example for the taxonomy so
if I want to get to lineage from one of
the tax IDs that I had on my table
and so there I've got the complete
lineage of one of those tax IDs again I
could line that up in exactly the same
way that we lined up the other things
what we want to do now is we're going to
use you fetch in a different way not
using XML but we're going to get the
protein sequences down so to do it with
a single record it's very simple it's
exactly the same command that we had
with you fetch before except this time
we're gonna get the fast date format
back there it is and to get all of them
is exactly analogous to what we did
before we're going to use you post to do
that we could just parse our file as we
did before we're gonna post it the
protein just like we did before we're
gonna I fetch it and we're gonna save it
in a file called proteins IFA if you
wanted to what I'll do is just let that
go down the screen so you can get all
the protein sequences that way okay and
that's basically what I wanted to cover
today there is an infinite number of
things that you could do certainly there
were much more sophisticated things you
can do if you want to get into like
parsing output if you really want to
parse out but you should probably parse
one of the structured formats but this
is a real simple thing these are simple
things you can do with that tab
delimited output once you have it on
your computer and you have these
additional tools to work with you can do
pretty much anything you want with it
anytime you want to it's okay so when we
learn how to do today we learned how to
download and process tabular blast
output using the UNIX command-line tools
the eater X suite of programs this slide
is at the end and you can certainly take
a look at this these is this is where
you can get more information about these
blasts and about edirect and let's open
it up for a few questions we're probably
going to run over time but we'll leave
it open for a couple minutes anybody has
a specific question
user rights and these tools are awesome
but there is a question about the number
does NCBI block the request when the
number of IDs are very high someone has
been having an issue with taxonomy so
the answer to the question is but do we
block people the answer is we do
sometimes but there's another problem
that these programs like you fetch in
particular there are basic limits
physical limits is the number of IDs it
can process and so if you're in the
areas of hundreds of thousands you
probably your requests probably won't
work so you know if you're gonna do that
kind of retrieval you'll want to work
with smaller files if you do things like
submit multiple requests simultaneously
where you're hitting the web servers you
know thousands of times a minute or
something like that
yes we will block you based on the IP
but e feds will fail with large numbers
of IDs for a fairly experienced scripter
they have a question is a post better
than just a bash loop I'm not sure I
understand what you're trying to say but
e posts is if you're trying to submit
one of the things that we really don't
like people doing there are many people
who do this they use scripts and they
submit IDs one at a time and we don't
want you to do that if that's what you
mean by a bash loop what we want you to
do is to use e post and submit the IDs
and batches and then get them down that
way user asks is there an alternative to
e direct tools to retrieve data from
local copies or their mirrors of some of
the NCBI databases an alternative to e
direct for retrieval so no there's a
direct is basically these are just
wrappers around our URL API so they're
they're accessing the entre system at
NCBI which is not you can't install that
locally and there are no real mirrors of
that system anywhere I hope that answers
a question I mean if you have your own
local database of things
you would using some kind of database
program like SQL or something like that
to access a database okay I think that's
all we have time for if there are
questions that we didn't answer that you
know you've sit in the question spot
will certainly answer them in the
document that I'm going to produce it
has the questions and answers in it so
thanks everybody for coming and we'll
see you next time